(percussive jazz music)
- [Voiceover] There's sun.
There's sand.
There's speed.
Well, hold on.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
(vintage music)
In 1947, 100 miles east of LA,
a bunch of World War II vets
formed a car club called the Oilers,
taking their Model T
Fords, hot-rodding them up
and racing them in the Mojave desert.
Eventually, the men got
old, the cars broke down,
and their brand of bare-knuckle
drag racing all but stopped.
Until now.
(percussive jazz music)
- My name is Mel Stultz.
I'm with the Race of Gentlemen.
My name's Bobby Green.
- [Voiceover] With the blessing
of the Oilers Club founders,
Mel and Bobby resurrected the club,
re-branding it the Race of Gentlemen.
(upbeat jazz music)
- What is the Race of Gentlemen?
It’s a vintage car race on the beach,
but there's that other layer to it.
(engine revving)
The Race of Gentlemen, in a
sense, is a time travel event.
We go to great lengths to
make it feel like you could be
in a different time era.
- [Voiceover] And the
rules of the race stay true
to the time period, as well.
The body, engine and running
gear must be of a certain age
and must be American-made.
- Well, there's definitely
something about American cars.
All those incredible cars that we created
starting from, let's say the 1910s
up until probably about
the 60s were so different
than anywhere else in the world.
Things today are made to last a month.
The 1932 Ford is made to last forever.
- It's not just about
the car and the bikes.
It's about the camaraderie
and all the things that go in.
People are like oh, this is so cool
because not only is it a
race, it's like a scene,
it's like a set.
It's lost in time.
- [Voiceover] And for
the Race of Gentlemen,
the love of classic American
cars transcends generations.
- [Mel] You've got young kids
that want to have a more simple life
and build and make things,
and them you've got the old generation.
We all kind of celebrate that time
when we built and we did
things with our hands.
(motor humming)
- [Bobby] The Race of
Gentlemen is definitely helping
to keep this sport alive
with a new generation.
(upbeat jazz music)